The prophet Muhammad sallallah.aihi
wasallam told us that whoever builds a
mosque for Allah, Allah will build for
him a sim house in Jenna. And we know
the great reward that will not only be
gained but rather will fill your grave
after your death. Whenever someone prays
there, whenever someone gives shahada in
the masid, whenever someone learns
something in the masid, yes, that will
be something that you'll have on your
scale.
>> [applause]
>> There's one thing we can all agree on
that the universe
is regular, stable, uniform. The extent
to which it allows life to exist within
it. From every small atom to the largest
of celestial spheres, we see incredible
goal directedness
within
the cosmos. Now the question is
what is the best explanation for that?
Is it a source of knowledge
or is it a lack thereof?
This is the question that must be asked.
Is it a source of knowledge
or is it a lack thereof?
Another question that could be asked is
that did something come from nothing?
Is it conceivable, intelligible or
plausible for something to come from
nothing that the universe came from
nothing? Did the universe generate and
cause itself? Well, to suggest that the
universe was generated or caused itself
is tantamount to saying
that a mother gave birth to herself.
And to suggest that there's more than
one ultimate source of being, more than
one necessary existence
is tantamount to saying that you can
have more than one mother to one soul
child.
Therefore, it is clear
that monotheism, the idea of one source,
that is the foundation
for everything that exists is the only
reasonable conclusion.
Another question that must be asked is
what is the purpose of life?
What is the purpose of life? Imagine
going into work.
You don't know who your boss is. You
don't know what your role is.
You don't know what you're doing there.
But here we are in the career of life.
And we don't know what our purpose is.
The purpose of life is to align the
finite with the infinite.
The purpose of life is to submit to the
lawgiver.
ultimate source of all creation. That's
why
prophets and messengers were sent a four
time.
Abraham, Moses,
Jesus, and for us the final prophet
Muhammad sallallahu alaihi wasallam.
And these prophets came
to expound on this truth to tell people
to submit to God. And they came with an
evidence for their prophethood. As for
the prophet Muhammad, his evidence
is that he came with a preserved
religion. The Quran is preserved in a
way that no other ancient book is.
There's a falsification test within the
Quran
challenging humanity to find a
contradiction within it. Challenging
humanity to try and produce a chapter
like it.
And the prophet of Islam made
predictions that were so frequent and so
precise
that no other figure in human history
made them. For example,
he told us that the Roman Empire and the
Persian Empire would both fall to the
Muslims.
Now, according to Barnaby Rogerson, who
is a historian,
non-Muslim historian, he said that the
similitude of the Arabs at that time
taking over the Persian and Roman Empire
is the same as Eskimos taking over
Russia and America. Imagine what kind of
a wild prediction this is. And this is
one of many predictions that obviously I
don't have time to expound here. The
question is what does atheism have to
offer?
Atheism has no explanatory force
whatsoever.
Atheism is a negation. Atheism has no
onlogical status.
Atheism cannot describe or explain
morality, rationality, consciousness.
Atheism brings nothing to the table.
With that, I conclude withamlaykumah.
[applause]
Same question and then could you restate
the question for me?
>> Question is between
systems the most.
So I would say that secularism as the
foundation for the very least the system
of governance that we have and the way
that our laws and the way that we
dictate how we conduct ourselves I think
is superior to any individual religious
system because it allows for um all
these different viewpoints to come
together. Uh I think that it is no
coincidence that we are in a relatively
secularly governed country where we have
the ability for somebody to speak on
their religion and they can say what
they want about it. they can have their
beliefs about it and I have the ability
or anybody else here has the ability to
disagree with that particular viewpoint
but there's still room in society for
that viewpoint. Um I would say that one
of the foundational errors or one of the
foundational mistakes or
incompatibilities that the more
fundamentalist approach or the more
hardcore approach to religion has led to
is the intolerance in certain societies
of other types of beliefs. So whether
that is the way that you conduct
yourself and how you do comedy or
speech, whether that's the way that you
um set up your particular neighborhoods,
whether that's the types of laws that
you pass to allow freedoms for other
people in society, especially people
that have traditionally been oppressed
by systems of governance, um could be
different types of minority figures, it
could be women, it could be people of
LGBT status. I think that the more
secularized society is superior because
it creates space for all of those people
to exist together in a system that is
functional. Um, I think that there is
some conversation to be had about the
nature of existence. I do think that
it's nice that religion gives us easy
answers and all of our big branches of
philosophy. You don't have to do much
ethics, much metaphysics, much ep um
epidem uh epistemology uh when it comes
to figuring your religious beliefs
because all the answers are kind of
there for you. And maybe that allows you
to explore other things in life. But
when it comes time to arguing those
things to other religious people, the
last I checked, I don't think that Islam
or Christianity or Judaism uh have
settled their disagreements between who
is the one true religion uh
Abrahamically or any of the other number
of religions that people choose from. So
I think that in terms of societal
progression, in terms of the moral
progress, you could say that we've seen
as a society, I think that a larger
secular umbrella has allowed this to
happen. I don't think it is a
coincidence that people find themselves
moving more and we'll talk about
immigration later to these more western
secularized societies because these
societies have such specific carveouts
for different types of beliefs and
different types of religions to exist
and to express themselves. And I think
that having these countries change back
to regress into a more religious state
into a more fundamentalist state where
all of us are required to have a
particular religious belief I think
would be a regression in the I would say
philosophical progress that we've made
as a society. um or as multiple
societies because um yeah the idea of
being able to enforce your religious
ideology or your dogma on some
particular group of people um I think is
is an idea that was tried in the past
and hasn't produced the societies that
have the most flourishing today which I
would say are the ones that are more
secular and do allow for more different
uh points of view.
Well, I mean, Destiny mentions that
secularism is superior to religion, but
secularism couldn't exist without it
because secularism is by definition a
separation between church and state. So,
how can you have secularism without the
church? You would just have something
else. So, it can't be superior to it
because it incorporates it into its
worldview. But the question really is,
what's the objective basis for all of
his claims? He mentioned LGBT and
minority this this that and the other.
The question is as an atheist who
believes that we are essentially atoms
whizzing around.
This is the physicalist. This is THE
MATERIALIST ASSUMPTION. HOW CAN you get
from that to objective morality in the
first place? How can you ascertain that
liberalism is the superior ideology from
first principles from a scientific or
mathematical perspective? You can't do
that. It's not possible because Kant
couldn't do that because JS Mill
couldn't do that because greater people
than me and you couldn't do that.
Therefore, you won't be able to do that.
Secondly, I will say this. I mean he
mentioned something about intolerance
which we'll come to in a second but
he mentions
and I was very surprised when I to be
honest with you heard this he mentions
intolerance let's go to this straight
away actually
this is a man who supports a genocide
this is a man who was going to the IDF
telling the IDF that you know when
you're doing your atrocities make sure
you hide them and don't take pictures of
You're going to talk to us about You're
going to talk to us about this. You're
going to be sanctimonious and talk about
minority rights. What minorities are you
talking about? The minorities that you
prefer, that the white man prefers,
that the colonialists prefer.
That's the minorities that you when it
comes to the Palestinians. No, no, no,
no. Kill them. You're actually telling
people to kill them. This is absolutely
diabolical.
And with that, I will conclude. Then you
can respond.
>> [applause]
>> There are what some two billion Muslims
I think on the planet. For all the talk
I hear of Islam coming from one book,
from one word that is unchanged and
unaltered, uh I look to the Palestinian
situation and I wonder where is Islam or
where are the Muslims? The idea that
there is some foundational religion here
that all of these different people of
the same belief system buy into enough
to actually stand up for and defend and
support their fellow Muslim brother
doesn't seem to be there. So, one of the
most fatal flaws that I find people who
are religious commit is this flaw of
thinking they stand on firmer ground
than they actually do. The idea that
there is one holistic unified view of
Islam is probably a view that every
individual Muslim would tell you, but
maybe not all of them would agree on. I
think the same can be said for
Christianity. The same can be said for
probably any major religion. Um you know
we can talk about what type of
minorities that we prefer but I mean if
you just take a glance at any western
society you can see that the
incorporation of different groups of
people into these societies is much
better and the net is cast much wider
than it is in any comparable societies I
would say in the Middle East or North
Africa region.
>> Okay.
He says, "Where are the Muslims?" That's
a good question and I agree with him on
that actually. But there's a distinction
to be made between Muslims and Islam.
The discussion here is not about
Muslims. It's about Islam. That's the
first thing. And then he says, okay,
well, Western countries are doing a good
job of minorities. I mean, liberalism
coexisted with colonialism. You must
understand this. You cannot look at this
time in history and not realize that JS
Mill was somebody who was actually
advising his government how to use
racism and supremacy against the
colonial empire against members of the
colonial empire the colonies. So that's
there has been a relationship between
racism on the one hand and colonialism
on the other and it's very well known.
Look what happened to India. This is a
really bad argument. But the question is
not about liberalism.
It's about atheism and there is no
necessary connection between atheism and
liberalism. You can be an atheist
communist. You can be an atheist Nazi.
You can be an atheist Zionist as you
are. As you are. He is importing He is
importing. Huh? He's importing
liberalism into the discussion to save
atheism. Sorry to say just as because
he's open about this open relationship
stuff. just as he imports other men to
help with his conjugal duties.
You You have no business talking about
liberalism.
You have no business talking about
liberalism. We're not talking about
liberalism. Liberalism is a philosophy
that's not on the debate card today. We
are talking about atheism. Tell me how
you can get to objective morality from
atheism. Tell me how you can get to
atoms whizzing around carbon which we
are from is to ought as David Hume would
put it. Otherwise you'd be doing the
naturalistic fallacy. If you can't do
that then be a man. It's going to be
very hard sorry to say for you. Very
hard. Be a man and say I concede the
debate. I give up. I throw the white
towel. Although maybe you'll be using
that white towel for other things. But
if you can't do that honestly it's done.
The debate is finished
and that's all I have to say.
[applause]
So I think at the end of the day, you
know, you can talk about the Adams
whizzing by. We can talk about um the
different ways that we think we've
proven our God, but again, there's been
no progress made on this conversation in
the thousands of years that people have
debated religion. I think that one of
the fatal flaws again of religious
people is that they stand on or they
think they stand on firmer ground than
they actually do. Uh you say that we're
not talking about Muslims, we're just
talking about Islam. Different people
have different interpretations of what
Islam means. Some people might think
that uh marriage is between one man and
a woman who want to spend the rest of
their life together. Other people might
believe that marriage is a thing that
you solicit to a woman to engage in sex
with her and then leave her immediately
after. Um other people have different
views on that. It just depends on how
you live your life. The great thing
about liberal societies is you're able
to practice all of these things however
you want in a way that won't involve you
getting executed for it. um when it
comes to deciding you know whether a
society can have a secular foundation
you know you can have this conversation
of well philosophically you can't
connect A to B and B to C and C to D and
everything else but somehow secular
society seemed to exist uh it's also
funny to try to try to try to tie
liberalism together in with this concept
of imperialism when people have been
doing imperialism far before the concept
of liberalism even existed I seem to
remember caliphat spreading across uh
huge portions of the world and they
didn't need any liberalism to do that
they seem to do that just fine along
with Islam Islam has specific categories
of people that aren't part of the uh
main body of the Muslim population. So
this idea that you can't have
marginalized people and any type of
system I think is a bit silly. Uh the
idea that Islam provides some special
protection or some special way to run a
society that would be superior in terms
of the uh producing better outcomes for
the people involved. Where are those
countries? That would be my big
question. You know, if we were to argue
about the successes of liberalism, I
mean, I could point to Muslims existing
in a liberal country today with the
ability to argue for their Muslim
countries. How many Muslim countries can
I go to and find liberals arguing the
same thing? I think that the idea of
free speech, open debate, uh the ability
to own private property, to start a
business you want, and to practice
whatever religion you want. I think it's
a special thing that liberal societies
have created. And I challenge the
opposing speaker to tell me what are
these model Arab societies? What are
these model Muslim societies? What are
these modern Islamic societies or these
model Islamic societies you would want
us to look more like than any of the
countries in the west that you found
appropriate to live in?
[applause]
>> Sure.
Well, that was a bit of a mouthful,
Bonelli. But you're going to have to
swallow your pride and concede the
debate because actually he has not been
able to connect the dots unfortunately
for himself.
This is a debate about Islam and
atheism. Not Islam and liberalism. Okay?
He is assuming a liberal framework.
Liberalism does not necessarily connect
with atheism in any way whatsoever.
itself. Liberalism needs proof and
justification for its own truth, which
we can do in maybe another debate. I
don't think you're going to be wanting
to do any other debates after this. But
the fact of the matter is this. He says,
"Muslim countries," that's his big
question. Where are the Muslim? I agree
with you. Muslim countries are not
following Islam. This is the answer to
your question. They are not following.
Muslim countries are not follow. Look at
the Palestine issue. There are
non-Muslim countries who have done a
better job than a Muslim country to the
Palestine issue. you know, they've acted
more Islamic than the Muslim countries
have. I agree with this criticism. We
are not talking about that as he's
talking about execution and this and
that. How dare you talk about execution.
You are speaking to the IDF telling them
if you're going to commit atrocities,
don't bring your phone out. You are in
no position whatsoever to talk about
rights to us today. No position. Zero.
Your sanctimony is gone and you are
finished. I'm sorry to say.
[applause]
As much as the fellow speaker wants to
pay me as a Zionist Israeli person, I've
never given a speech to the IF. I don't
think they would much want my advice or
my criticisms. Not a fan of Netanyahu.
Never have been. Uh we could glad get
into that later if you'd like.
um you're talking about the ability to
connect atheism to liberal society and
you're saying that I'm simply begging
that that I'm simply asserting that it
must be true for one uh liberal society
to exist that there must be some atheist
foundation. But I guess my question to
you would be how could you have a
foundation to a society that is some
kind of religion that also allotss for
other religions to practice themselves
in identical ways. Um when religions
tend to be mutually exclusive especially
the Abrahamic ones when they say that my
holy book, my scripture, my God, my
interpretation is the correct one. How
do you truly have a society where you
allow for other people to practice their
religious beliefs? I challenge you. I'm
curious, you know, in in your worldview
in the ideal Islamic country, would you
allow people to draw pictures of the
prophet, would you allow people to
practice whatever religion they want? Um
would you allow people to do things that
so long as they comport with the basic
laws that we all agree on when it comes
to you know things like don't steal,
don't murder, don't do uh you know
obvious crimes we all agree on, would
you allow in your ideal Islamic society
all of these other religions to practice
in the same way that in a liberal
society uh in an atheist society in a
secularly built society other religions
are able to practice.
[applause]
Jesus, he asked me a series of questions
and he said that would you allow the
drawing of the prophet? Would you allow
this? Would you allow that? In the same
way as liberal societies, why should it
be the same way? You haven't proven
liberalism is true and you haven't
proven that atheism is true. You've
given us no arguments for anything. And
then he says free speech. Well, it's
very interesting he mentions free speech
because I going through some of his
content and he was making an argument
for child and he in fact said that
there's a pragmatic case for child. So
yes, the Muslim countries would actually
ban something like that and that is an
inhibition to the free speech people
like you. Atheist morality would bring
to the table. Child banned in the Muslim
countries for example. Maybe that will
put you in trouble or this and that cuz
I know you sent some pictures to that
person, that person, whatever. I don't
know what's going on. I'm surprised
you're even here today. So quite
frankly,
I I was thinking whether or not I should
humiliate you, but I was worried that
maybe you enjoy it.
It's over here, man. You haven't
answered any of my questions. I'm asking
you, how do you connect atheist morality
with liberalism? There is no answer.
There's no connection. So, all of your
subsequent questions are waste of time
because you are a puny perverse.
Yes, I'm sorry to say puny. Perverse
pro- genocide pipsqueak of an
individual. This is the case and there's
nothing more to be said about you.
[applause]
respond as well.
>> I would have prepared more personal
insults if I knew that was the direction
we were taking this. But okay. Um,
again, I will say, you know, you're
saying that I haven't connected atheism
to a liberal society, but I noticed that
you failed to answer my question of what
types of behaviors would you allow in
your model Islamic society without
having the foundation as some secular
system, without being able to point to
laws, without being able to point to a
system of governance that doesn't
originate from some holy book. I don't
know how you can say that a liberal
society, one that allows for all
religions to practice equally, isn't
necessarily a society that doesn't take
a normative position on what religion is
true or what religion is false. Uh
again, there is a reason why you have
come to this country. And while you
might insult me and call me a lot of
names, uh which funny enough is an
indication that the person doesn't feel
confident in the material, I guess, that
they're talking about. Uh you have the
right to do that and you're able to do
that here as a I don't know if you were
born in this country, if you're an
immigrant to this country. And I think
that's a beautiful thing. I don't think
that you would be able to get away with
the same type of behavior in the
countries that you seem to want to model
this one or other western countries out
of. Again, I ask you if you think that
there is a better way to build a country
with an Islamic foundation, where are
these countries? It seems like they fell
in the past. They haven't emerged again.
If you're telling me that atheism is not
the model or is not the foundation for a
secular liberal society that allows for
other religions to practice equally,
well, then tell me what is the religious
foundation for that society? How can you
have a society that allows for multiple
religions to practice all of them to be
treated in equal in an equal manner by
the laws and the government but say that
that society takes some position on
religion and that the society itself
isn't atheist or is it liberal? Um you
brought up this idea earlier. It's funny
you used an analogy of uh you know a
mother birthing herself or a child
having two mothers. We can look for
instance to children born today that
doesn't involve any religious aspect. It
doesn't involve a god. It doesn't
involve anything else. We know the
process by how that works. We don't need
religion right now to explain the things
that are happening in society. For all
the predictions that Muhammad or anybody
else supposedly made about things in
society, I don't see his name on any
research papers. I haven't seen him
publish anything in Nature or Science
Weekly. I don't really know what his
predictions are doing that are relevant
today. I know that, you know, he was the
head of a bunch of caliphates that or
started these that eventually fell and
no longer exist. So, I'm just curious if
in your push to have Islam be the model
for western society again, where are
these countries that you want to model
um you know, western countries off of?
And if my foundation for a liberal
society is not an atheist one, then tell
me what religion am I pointing to in
order to have the societies that exist.
[applause]
That now we move on to our next segment
which is on immigration. Immigration has
also the west it [snorts] streets it
schools and census for some
other
some cultural
formation.
My question to both of you is
multiculturalism destined to fail.
>> So I think that one of the fatal flaws
that western countries have made
especially the United States is we don't
really ask ourselves what does it mean
in my country to be an American. I think
that there are good reasons to celebrate
immigration. uh you can look at the
numbers side, you can look at the
economic impacts, the fiscal impacts,
the impacts to business and everything
else and you would say well immigration
is beneficial there. Um you can look at
certain aspects of culture and say that
we're enriched when it comes to foods or
entertainments or arts and you know you
say there's an enrichment there but what
does it mean to actually be an American?
What is the core base of values that all
of us should be sharing? I when I look
at countries in the west today uh
especially after the Syrian refugee
crisis especially 2013 onwards
especially postrexit in the United
Kingdom I feel like we haven't come
together in a long time in a lot of
these countries especially in mine I
can't speak as much for yours but we
haven't come together and asked
ourselves what does it mean to be a
member of our nation and what kind of
values should we be looking for from
people that are coming to our nation um
again I will hearkening back to the last
subject I like the concept of liberalism
as a secular government because as long
as we share some core values that we're
all working and building towards some
concept of a nation that we're working
and building towards. Liber liberalism
provides a lot of different paths to get
there. Um, a Muslim like Bumani in New
York can be the mayor of New York City,
which is a wonderful thing. We have
evangelical Christians in the United
States. I would say that they're less
wonderful things, but I'm glad that they
have the right to exist. Um, we have
secular atheists. We've got Zionists and
non-Zionist Jews. We've got all sorts of
different types of people that can exist
under this umbrella, all working towards
a common goal. Uh, I think that when you
have people that are proponents of
immigration, I think that it's good to
take a step back sometimes and think,
well, what do we want our country to
look like? What kind of people should we
want to come here? And that doesn't just
mean people that look or think like us.
It means people that are building
towards some kind of common goal. And I
think for people that are harshly
critical of immigration, I think it's
good for them to ask the same question.
Do I want nobody coming here because
they don't look like me or because they
don't think exactly like me? Uh, and
what kind of restrictions would I draw
on immigrants coming here that I
wouldn't also restrict on my own
countrymen? I notice sometimes in the
United States, for instance, that a lot
of conservatives will talk about how we
want to restrict immigration from people
that have A, B, and C or X, Y, and Z
thoughts that they feel like aren't
aligned with American values. But I
would point to a lot of conservatives in
the United States. And I would say that
your disregard for rule of law or the
Constitution doesn't align with our
values. So I think that if you're going
to have a view on immigration, I think
that you should have first a view on
what your nation is and what it looks
like. And then you should try to
incorporate more and more people as long
as you're building towards that final
project or vision.
>> [applause]
>> this well I think uh with this one the
interlocator and I'm not going to
disagree that much as much as we did in
the uh previous one but what I will say
is that when we think about it when we
talk about immigration and what's
happening now in the media especially
visav Muslim immigration Muslim
immigrants the sons of immigrants I mean
he asked me you came to this country I
didn't come to this country I I was born
in this country. You're the one who
came, sorry to say, to this country as a
as a visitor. Uh you don't have to be
white to be actually um somebody who
belongs to this country. And that's the
point. Look, people are talking about
grooming gangs, unemployment,
criminality, and these kind of things
visally the Muslim population. But when
was the last time you heard that despite
a 6%
population, the Muslims are 6% of this
country that they constitute 22%
according to Christi Foundation, NHS
Foundation of the medical professionals
in the NHS. In fact, 51% of the NHS are
comprised of people who are immigrants
or the sons of immigrants. If you remove
that, you will have a crisis so large it
will be as if Britain went into war. You
cannot People have this discussion about
immigration.
They disregard the fact for example that
Muslims once again are four times
according to Charity UK more likely to
give to charity than their non-Muslim
counterpart. Muslims contribute 70
billion per year to the UK economy which
is equivalent to Birmingham and
Manchester combined. the output of those
two things. Now, if you remove all those
contributions, you will have a cascading
impact in Britain that is so far
reaching that will dent the economy and
it will bring death and destruction upon
the people of Britain. The question
isn't about, oh, we can have this
discussion about immigration. You need
us. You need the immigrants. Don't speak
in a position of privilege as if we
can't have. You actually need the
immigrants.
you're in a position where you are
dependent on immigrants. This country is
dependent on immigrants and the sons of
immigrants. And then he talks about the
Syrian refugee crisis. I don't even know
what point he made frankly. Sorry, I I
didn't wasn't listening very clearly and
the microphone is not that clear for me.
But exactly Syrian refugee crisis. If
you support a genocide
in Palestine,
you support it and people then run away
from Palestine to try to come to the
west, then you are the architect of your
own complaints. You are the you are
creating the conditions of your own
complaints. In other words, if the
western powers decide to go into these
different countries
like Iraq, like Afghanistan,
like Syria, like Libya,
like Palestine will help those who are
doing it. And then those people that
start fleeing and coming to Europe, you
created this issue.
So what do you what do you want to do
with these people? You either bomb them
when they're there, when they try and
run away, you you say no to them as
well. Sorry to say, what kind of a
situation is this?
What kind of situation? Let's talk about
integration and assimilation
unemployment.
According to the BBC, if you have a
Muslim name, you're three times less
likely to be employed by the same job
for the same position.
So, I would say yes, it's true. There
are some legitimate concerns with
immigration. There are legitimate
concerns with minority groups. I'm not
going to deny that. And there has to be
some concession made. There are there
are there are things we have to work on
as every community in Britain. But at
the same time, the way forward is there
to be a reciprocity between the
government or the dominant population
and these minority groups. And there
needs to be a reduction to the barriers
of discrimination.
[applause]
So I think we maybe agree on a bit of
immigration. Um although I think uh the
priorities are a little bit different uh
in terms of certain groups of people. Uh
when I'm having conversations or debates
on immigration, one of the things I tend
to look for is how much people mix up
groups of people or how wide of a net
people cast when they talk about certain
groups of people. So I can't speak to
the particular numbers on immigration in
the United Kingdom. But I do think it
was interesting that it seemed like
simultaneously a very high percentage of
immigrants. Uh maybe Muslims in
particular were doctors, but also a very
high percentage of people or much higher
percentage of people that name Muhammad
are unemployed. So clearly we're talking
about different groups of immigrants
here. But I think it's probably worth it
to pay attention to different groups of
immigrants. I think that one of the big
mistakes that people have made is in
allowing immigrants to come up and
improve your economy. The economy
improving is not the same thing as life
for an individual improving. And
sometimes there are ways to bring in
immigrants to a country where the
overall economy improves, but there are
the improvement is slight over the
entire economy, but the destruction to
parts of the economy are very
concentrated and are very noticed. And
especially in the United States, we have
issues along our manufacturing sector
where you can see concentrated damage
that different types of immigration have
caused. While the entire country might
benefit, the people that are in those
damaged sectors will obviously feel like
they've been abandoned by their nation,
by their country. And I think there's a
legitimate grievance there that should
be addressed. So, as long as you are
balancing out immigration, the types of
immigrants who want to come in, it's
important to distinguish different types
of immigrants from other types of
immigrants. A doctor who wants to come
to the UK or the United States from
Syria is going to be a lot different
than an asylum seeker coming from North
Africa is going to be a lot different
than a PhD researcher coming from Kenya
is going to be a lot different than a
supposed asylum seeker from South
Africa. All of these people are
different and you have to look at them
in kind of their disperate groups and
you know assess which ones you want in
your country and how you want them to
contribute. And I'm very hesitant to
take advice or critique from somebody
talking about immigration who's very
quick to lump all of these groups
together and imply that we should treat
all of them somewhat equally.
[applause]
>> Yeah. So unemployment was mentioned
again
and as I mentioned look when it comes to
criminality and unemployment this is the
main argument that people make against
immigrations or migrants or ethnic
minorities right the fact is there are
two major predictors for those things
okay number one is being a man if you
are a man you are more likely to be a
criminal okay maybe 10 times more likely
than a woman no one's going to ban men
from the country okay no one's going to
say okay the UK Okay, no men are allowed
in because actually you're represented
to a degree of 10 to or 100 to one
wherever it may be in prisons. So there
has to be some discussion about okay
well what are the parameters? Now the
second predictor is actually
socioeconomics. Now in in the in the UK
and in Western Europe the issue is that
it's different to the way it happened in
the United States. When the United
States people brought people in for
immigration they had more select
criterion. Okay they brought in middle
class people. That's why there's no talk
of grooming gangs in Pakistani
communities in California. There's no
talk of it whatsoever. Why? Because
they're middle class because they're
doctors and engineers. In other words,
when you are poorer, you're more likely
to commit more crimes in certain areas.
This regardless of race, religion, or
whatever it may be,
wealth is the predictor. It's
soioeconomics.
So, it's not, oh, these black people are
coming in and they're doing this, these
Mexican people. No, when you get a black
man and a white man who have the same
money, they're likely to commit the same
crimes and be unemployed in the same
level, etc., etc. So, the point is the
immigration thing has missed the
colonial aspect. Britain's history with
colonialism mean meant that it called
the people from ex colonies to come into
Britain as unskilled labor after the
world war in order to fix their country.
They can't just do that and then tell
them to leave afterwards. And hence the
reason why you've got people from
Pakistan or from Jamaica or from
whatever India in England is because
they were ex- colonies and that these
people are were used as unskilled labor
and because they're in that
socioeconomic bracket they will be more
likely in some areas to commit certain
crimes or to be unemployed just by
virtue of socioeconomics. But that's not
an argument against Islam. It's not an
argument against or race realist
argument or whatever it may be because
that's where it's veering towards.
That's the right-wing argument that
they're doing it because of their
religion. They're doing it because of
their race and that's what we should be
against because actually the data is
against all of that. So when we're
having the discussion about immigration,
the connection, the causal connection
between these aspects which they
consider to be wrong on the one hand and
what's going on in someone's religion or
someone's race on the other is there is
no connection and the connection is
actually a socioeconomic one.
[applause]
I don't think I disagreed much with what
was said. I will say that when you're
talking about different groups of
immigrants though, it's important that
morality enters the conversation
depending on which groups of immigrants
that we are talking about. I think that
there's a mistake sometimes that when we
point to immigration, we only talk about
the benefits, but then we talk about
different groups of immigrants and then
sometimes we speak of obligations that
we have to those immigrants. Um, in the
United States, typically most of the
immigrants that we bring in are just by
virtue of us having oceans separating us
from the rest of the world. They're
going to be more wealthy. They're going
to be higher educated. You're selecting
from these kind of higher echelons of
society. When these people come in, the
expectation for my country and the
expectation for any country, I would
imagine for everyone to come in is that
on net you're going to benefit the
country in a variety of ways. I don't
think that that same expectation should
be levied though towards people that are
seeking asylum or for people that are
fleeing disaster. I think that sometimes
when people again are looking at all of
these different groups the same. I think
that it's okay to say that there are
going to be some groups that at least
for some period of time either while
they're there or if they stay there are
going to be at least fiscal or budget
drains on your society because the
situation that they're coming from isn't
one that built them to be an economic
unit or powerhouse that can contribute
to your country. the obligations that we
have towards different groups of
immigrants, the obligations that we have
towards asylum seekers should be as
successful and relatively speaking
wealthy countries that we can take some
amount of people in. It's our goodwill
for the world. You can even argue to I
would argue to a much smaller extent
because I don't buy into the uh
colonialist arguments as much, but you
can argue that because of the west
impact on other parts of the world that
we have some obligation as well to take
care of people that might be fleeing
disaster from there, especially places
in the Middle East. Um, but that being
said, we have to be able to talk about
all of these different groups, the
different expectations that we have of
these groups and then the different ways
morally that we would approach these
groups in terms of how we would allow
them into our society and then how we
would incorporate them into our society,
what our expectations of them would be
and what our expectations of our own
country would be with regards to the
treatment of those groups of people.
[applause]
>> Sure. Uh so with this I mean he mentions
the expectations and he talks about
morality and we've already had this
discussion. He can't even establish what
morality is or how it's true or anything
like that. He's assuming the truth of
his worldview without arguing for it
which is pathetic actually. This is a
debate. You're meant to actually argue
for your world view whether it's
liberalism or atheism. There's no
evidence given. But the second thing is
that if you if people have this view
like for example they say well Muslims
conservative Muslims will be against the
liberal paradigm in these areas. The
same thing applies for Jews then because
frankly the most two closest religions
are strict conservative Muslims and
strict conservative Jews. If you want to
have one policy for one, don't not have
the other policy for the other cuz
that's a double standard. But we have
never heard him speak about that. In
fact, he supports European Jewish
immigration into Palestine. So, it's not
like he's against immigration. I mean,
he he is not really that against
immigration anyway. But the point is
it's about who gets to benefit. That's
really the bottom line, isn't it? If
Europeans get to benefit, it's okay. No
problems. No questions asked. You can
even build settlements. You can even
build settlements. No problem. You can
even take steal someone's own. If you're
a European Jewish immigrant going into
Palestine, immigration is fine. But if
you're someone coming out into the UK,
no, this discussion about expectations
now. Actually, if you're seeking asylum,
are you seeking asylum? You created
these walls. You bombed these people.
They're running for their life. And now
before you come in, tell us what you're
going to bring to the table. Is this is
this a joke? Is this some kind of a is
this satire?
This is pathetic. Frankly, no argument
has been given. If you don't want asylum
seekers and refugees in these European
countries, then don't create wars in
those countries.
We are here because they were there.
That's the reality of the situation.
Prevention is better than cure. Don't
create a disaster and then ask why is it
happening? You created it with your own
hands.
[applause]
>> Yeah. Again, I mean, I don't really
disagree much, but I will say that if
you're going to have a conversation then
about different groups of immigrants
coming in, just be honest about what the
expectations are and be honest about how
you expect them to immigrate into your
society and integrate into your society.
You can't on one hand say that we have
caused disasters in regions of the world
and now we expect asylum seekers to come
because we owe it to them and then the
next breath say well actually all of
these people are going to contribute on
net to society at the same time. The
first thing is a moral obligation that
we would have to take care of a group of
people. The second is just an economic
trade and our expectations and our
approach to people is going to be wildly
different. Um I don't know if we're
going to get into Israel Palestine more
in the question section. Obviously, um
the other speaker here has a lot of
opinions on that, but um yeah, I would
say broadly we probably agree on
immigration. Just when you're having
conversations about immigration, make
sure that you're treating every group
differently. Make sure that you're
having an honest conversation about what
your expectations are of each group and
what your expectations are for those
groups once they're in your country and
how your country should treat those
groups.
question.
Not
Thank you.
identity
as a liberal justice
that
the
people
also
all of us
enjoy in this country.
the rest of the world. So
on this
matter we can
explain.
>> Well, I mean that's where the that's
Sir,
>> sure. Sure. I mean, look, in the western
ethical tradition, you'll be aware of
this. There's three main schools of
thought, right? There is
consequentialism,
there is deontological ethics, and then
there's virtue ethics of the ancients.
And all three of them attempt to tell us
how you can derive values, okay, without
religion. That was in fact exactly what
Kant tried to do through his categorical
imperative, his hypothetical imperative,
the universality of his laws, etc. The
issue is this. The issue is with those
three systems that are not religious
systems, whether it's canin or
deonttological, whether it's
consequentialist, utilitarian, which is
a subbranch of that, or whether it's
virtue ethics, none of them have a way
of proving themselves as objective
moralities. This is the problem. There
is no way of and they don't even some of
them don't claim that. Some of them
don't even claim that they're objective
moralities. So the point I'm making
today is when you talk about foundations
and stuff like that and that we all have
to agree the definition of an objective
morality is that despite people's
opinion this thing will stay the same
whereas subjective morality is it's like
that it's like that because of people's
opinion. So 2 plus 2= 4 will remain as
two 2 plus 2 4 even though there's no
one on the planet. So you cannot get
this as John Mackey said John Macki
wrote a very good he's an atheist
himself book on ethics called ethics
actually and at the end of it he
mentioned the following he said that the
only way you can do that is through a
list from God and he said that as an
atheist
[applause]
so I would approach religion and I would
approach morality for people when I
think of meta ethics when I think of
what is goodness I take an intuitive
view of it I don't think it's a
coincidence that almost every religion
almost Every culture seems to arrive at
these similar values, these similar
understandings of what's good and what's
not good. There are issues around the
edges around how we live our lives,
especially around say LGBT issues or
maybe the particular ways that we engage
with each other. But there seem to be a
core set of principles that emerge as a
boring materialist, I would say, from
the human biology. I don't think it's a
coincidence that when you grow up in a
Muslim household, you tend to be a
Muslim. I don't think it's a coincidence
when you grow up in a Christian
household, you tend to be Christian. Um,
and every other religion typically
follows suit. I think that we're largely
products of our environment. But I would
say that the shared values that we t
tend to have even from one culture to
the next, even from one religion to the
next is because there is an intuitive
understanding that we all have about
what is good and what is not good. Um
the systems that uh other speaker
brought up these kind of like normative
ethical models are different ways that
you can try to apply a metaethical
understanding of the world into how you
can live a better life. And you know we
can have disagreements around the edges
on that. Everybody's a consequentialist
until it comes time to go to the
hospital and a doctor wants to harvest
your organs to save other five other
people. Everybody's a dontologist until
the Nazis knocking at your door asking
if there's a Jew in the basement. Um the
reality is is I think we all use
intuition much more than we're willing
to admit and to center back on one of
the first things I said in this
conversation. Uh religious people find
themselves standing or they believe
they're standing on much firmer ground
than they ever actually are. In the
world of Christianity, even I as a
Catholic, my own arch dascese, my own
churches and my own city would have
disagreements on what it meant to be a
moral follower of Christ. What kind of
people do we allow to be uh parts of our
to allowed to have in different parts of
our church? When it comes to Islam,
there are different understandings of uh
whether or not you can trace your
descendants from uh I guess Muhammad or
whatever or your different types of Shia
city countries or different types of how
you practice religion in your different
countries, the different Muslims that we
have in the United States compared to
even the ones that are in Europe. So
even from a position of objective
morality or objective understandings of
the world, there's still billions of
people that have produced a plethora of
different beliefs concerning the system.
So if there is some religion that's able
to guide people towards some consistent
moral belief, that religion must just
have a member of one or I haven't seen
it yet.
Hi, thank you so much for being here.
So,
you mentioned
you yourself
be able to about the circumstances in
which it's okay to sexualize children
more that furthermore
was white national.
>> Yeah, I mean I did say that was relative
legally relative legally relative. In
other words, in the UK, the age of
consent is 16. In the US, it might be
18. In Russia, it might be 14. Which
means that by definition, this is a
factual statement. You're a profile with
different parameters if you go to
different countries. I don't think
that's a controversial statement at all,
my friend. As for what he said,
defending child through
consequentialism, one of your favorite
ethical systems is that is not something
about whether or not something is
objectively the case or a factual
statement. That is a moral prescriptive
thing. He's saying you can watch child
and it's actually could reduce the
amount of actual instances of failure
and therefore you can make a pragmatic
case for it. That's number one. Number
two, when he was making his giving his
answer, he committed two fallacies. One
of them was called the category mistake
fallacy. So he says we intuitit morals.
That's epistemology.
We're not talking about the
epistemological. I agree with that by
the way. We do intu intuitit some
morality. We're talking about the
ontological status of morality. How
morality quam morality can actually been
given objectivity. From what source is
it given objectivity? That's the first
thing. The second fallacy that he
committed was the if you want to call it
the genetic fallacy. Actually because of
something's origin it must be wrong. Oh
because you Muslims are born into Muslim
families are more you know born like
this or Christian. So same thing with
atheism. Atheism and liberalism doesn't
mean it's wrong. Therefore it's wrong.
Weak argument. Really weak. Very weak.
Very weak.
Yeah. And then furthermore he's he's
mentioned all interpretations. There's
so many interpretations of how many
people killed JFK. Was it this guy? That
guy? It doesn't mean no one killed him.
Just because there's so many
interpretations of Zoro doesn't mean it
doesn't exist.
[applause]
I'm going to take the bold stance to say
bad not good. I would also agree that
child bad and not good. Thank you. Um
[applause]
yeah, I guess we want to bring up uh
videos or whatever debates I've had in
the past. There was a man named Amosi
who I think is currently in prison for
abusing children. I is my understanding.
I don't know if he's out yet or not. Um
we had a conversation on whether or not
was acceptable. Again, I took the brave
stance that I don't think it's
acceptable. And the one hypothesis that
he proposed to me was something along
the lines of if there was older uh you
know material of children and it could
help not abuse children or whatever, is
this an okay thing? And I said I maybe I
don't know, but I don't even know if you
could do the research for that. Um but
this the idea of having some prop stance
that I have when again the opposing
speaker is saying that is relative I
think is an interesting line of
argumentation to go down. Um if you want
to look at explicit videos of mine or
whatever apparently I should open only
fans. There seems to be a lot of
interest around that. I have not had any
sexual relations with Nick Fuentes yet.
So who knows maybe in the future. We'll
see how that goes. But thank you. I
appreciate the uh fandom.
[applause]
So the last few
All right.
By the way,
>> [applause]
>> So I it's hard to hear with the echo,
but I think there was a reference to the
um when I was invited by uh Yo Golan
himself to give a conversation, I guess,
to the IDF. This was a group of fans of
mine at the time. There were pictures
circulating where I guess soldiers were
taking pictures in dresses. And the
question had to do with communicating
yourself to the Western world. And I
said, "Taking pictures like this is
obviously really stupid." Uh, if you
want to spin this into me saying, "If
you're going to commit war crimes, do it
off camera. I mean, you can do that.
That's fine. It's boring to me. This is
inconsistent with every belief I've ever
held in my life. But you're free to
shame me in whatever way makes you feel
better about yourself." When it comes to
the analysis of the region of whether or
not it's a genocide, personally, I think
this is a question for the International
Court of Justice and maybe historians. I
think that people that want to call it a
genocide are looking too hard to weigh
into some word or term or some
international definition that is somehow
going to bring peace to the region. And
I think it does a disservice to the
people there. And I think that it tries
to short circuit the argument of what
does a final resolution look like when
we're just screaming aparttheid, ethnic
cleansing, and genocide. I think that
the push in the west oftentimes that
people look for when they talk about
peace, when they talk about no more
killing is a very western centric view
that people involved in conflict don't
always necessarily share. When it comes
to Ukraine, the calls for peace are
usually from the Russian side saying,
"Well, we need peace so that we can take
25% of this country." Personally, I
believe that calls for just peace in
Israel Palestine is something that
Netanyahu supports because if you read
this 20point plan that's been floated,
it gives him essentially every single
thing that he wants in the region. I
think that once the bombs stop falling
and once Netanyahu works on his reform
of education in the uh Gaza Strip,
whatever that means. When he works on
his reform of the Palestinian Authority
into being less radical, whatever that
means. And then when he looks at all of
the other things that he's been granted
by the United States in order to build
whatever two separate uh societies that
he wants, I think that what's happened
is is even as we approach an end to this
conflict, Netanyahu's gotten everything
he wants and this claim of genocide
hasn't supported the Palestinian people
there in any way, size, shape, or form.
Well, first of all, about the child
aspect, he hasn't denied that he said
that. But more more significantly, he
said the following. Molesting kids is
not. That's a direct quote from you. So,
let's not play games here today. Your
atheistic morality is not granting you
any favors today. Look, if he cared
about kids, why is he supporting a
government?
Why if Yeah. Well, I will answer. I will
answer. Yeah.
I will answer
supporting a government that's killed
20,000 kids.
20,000 kids. We've seen the pictures of
them being incinerated and burnt and all
these kinds of things. And here you're
talking about minorities and minority
rights and morality and all these kinds
of things. and he denies the fact that
there's apartheid in Israel when in fact
the only ones who can return to Israel
are Jews.
How do you explain that there's no
apartheid in Israel when there are laws
that discriminate on the basis of eth?
Isn't that what you were just lecturing
us about? You were just telling us it
has to be equal. It has to be this.
You've never once condemned the IDF for
that. You've never once condemned Israel
for that. You know why? because you're
selective in your use of rights and
minority rights. It's the it's the
people that you want to have those
rights. But 20,000 children being
incinerated,
people being displaced, not a word of
condemnation, pin drop silence, and
that's why no one can ever take you
seriously again.
[applause]
I have a general question.
So
change
how
it
So this is how
was Right.
So something
changed.
So question how
It's a good question.
[applause]
It's a good question. I mean, the
misconception is that the only sources
of Sharia are the Quran and the Sunnah
or the Hadith. That's not actually the
case. I mean who is a scholar um 8th
century scholar he said that there are
11 different sources of the 11 and one
of them is actually or the idea of
detriments and harms which introduces a
kind of consequentialism actually there
is a kind of consequentialism in Islam
and there are principles which are
similar to the liberal tradition in
Islam but they operate on a different
priority so for example the harm
principle we have a harm principle as
well and it's based on the words of the
prophet he says which means that there
there's no harming or reciprocating
harm. So there is that and so where
there isn't an exact thing that is for
example mentioned in the Quran about a
specific issue that's happening today
then what the jurists will do is that
they'll use one of those principles okay
what is this thing is it harmful to the
people is it not harmful to me etc and
then they will make a ruling on the
basis of that so that answers the first
question terms of sali and the driving I
mean first and foremost there's no verse
in the Quran that says anything about
women cannot drive there's no hadith
that's in fact there's hadith showing
that women were riding the horse. It's
opposite. Yeah. So what was happening in
Saudi was something which is a cultural
thing in Saudi Arabia. Okay. Just like
in Afghanistan they do things which are
not Islamic. Taliban sometimes they'll
do something that's not Islamic. Not
every government that claims to do
something in the name of Islam is doing
that because the name of Islam. Okay. So
the point is is that our point of
defense is we defend that which is in
the Quran that was in the Sunnah. And
yes, we have principles of Jewish
prudence which basically govern all the
things that are not in those things um
including you know all the things that
you mentioned and and so forth. So there
is there is I would call it a Sharia
consequentialism but it's not it it
follows a different priority than let's
say liberal consequentialism or whatever
it may be.
[applause]
This is kind of why I find the objective
morality of religion a little bit
intellectually bankrupt. Um, I feel like
all you've done is you've kicked the
question of subjectivity down the road
from philosophers that you make fun of
by saying they have no objective
foundation for any of their moral truth
to what you call your religious scholars
who either they lack access to the
objective foundation of truth or they
also don't have objective um truth I
guess available to them despite the fact
that the Quran is written in one
language and is an unchanging document.
So when it comes to um yeah I guess when
it comes to making evaluations on um on
how to you know rule things as being
legal, how to rule things as being
illegal or how to evaluate these from a
moral perspective. The superiority I
would say from a secular framework is
that we can sit down and we can have
conversations about what do we think
builds towards a better society. What do
we think are the values that we all
share that we can kind of um that that
we can kind of agree on that we should
or shouldn't have a thing. So when it
comes to AI generated childpoint is a
topic that I see uh that gets brought up
in some communities um this is a it's a
challenging question for a variety of
reasons. Um maybe more uh more relevant
or thing that's been discussed in the
past are uh drawings of um there are
different names for these for animated
you know depictions of children or
whatever and you know is it a crime if
there isn't a victim? Uh is it a crime
if it leads to more victimization? If we
say yes does that mean that if we have
violent media that that's considered bad
because that could lead to more
violence. Um, yeah, there's there's a
you see there's like a huge mix of
consequentialist belief and
deontological belief and um, yeah, I
think sorting that out needs a bunch of
people to sit down and to honestly, you
know, be able to say I this is a tough
question and we're going to sit here and
we're going to write on and we're going
to argue back and forth and we're going
to see at the end of the day how many
people we can convince of what we
believe to be the morally correct option
here. I just I prefer the secular or
atheist view of that because at the end
of the day you can honestly say you're
having that conversation rather than
having 10 different people with 10
different ideas on say all of them have
objective truth about it.
[applause]
Thank you.
Thank you very much.
[applause]